maintenant se replonger il ya 20 ans il
ya vingt ans il avait 21 ans et
lorsqu'il est arrivé dans la maison on
l'a reconnu qu'il avait une coiffure
bizarre un peu peroxydée il était fan de
bourriques et surtout ils écoutent et
mylène farmer du matin au soir
regardez vous l'avez trouvé le futur
voilà il est 14 heures se couche à 6 ans
le matin je suis fatigué et j'ai su quoi
faire me refaire une rénovation de
façade stevie à 21 ans il vit la nuit
savent ils seulement le lieu préféré
2stv
c'est le salon de coiffure de son ami
olivier il vient ici tous les jours pour
retrouver les amis qu'ils mi6 thiviers
est une star sa plus belle histoire
d'amour c'est aura sa maman qui l'a eu à
18 ans depuis ils ne se quittent plus
parce que manche entre à regarder les
photos des steevy quand il était petit
je vais beaucoup à danser
stevie est barman dans une discothèque
du monde pour ce soir là ne se doute pas
que l'équipe de m6 lui a préparé une
surprise
jean-sébastien un sosie de mylène farmer
va lui annoncer en direct sa
participation définitive à l'émission
loft story
on se situe
[Applaudissements]
et voilà et voilà on reviendra en
arrière ya 20 ans était un jardin steevy
personne ne connaissait l'aller pour
entrer dans l'histoire de la télé
réalité il faisait partie du premier
casting de la ville a été de la première
téléréalité il est là il pas sortir les
sites allemands évidemment comme à
l'époque ou alors ils n'arrivent pas à
ouvrir la porte encore possible il
faudrait qu'ils sortent évidemment ah
bah oui on lui ouvre la porte à la la
alors ils ont trop chaud et beau gosse 1
or maintenant il a un petit côté jean
marc barr il est plus blond évidemment
là mon cv
ah la la
oh la la
on doit rester à distance
c'est très heureux que voilà un mot
c'est fait l'arrêt mais magnifique mais
tu es magnifique
bon on décompte ya 20 ans stevie
apparaissait pour la première fois la
télévision c'était il ya vingt ans alors
l'époque le temps passe alors pourquoi
des cheveux ne sont plus blond aubin ont
vieilli et ai été très beau c'était un
petit côté d'un petit côté jean marc
barr la valise alors avalé je vous
explique
au cours de la soirée en fait il y aura
un petit a eu l'oeil de ce casting qui
va tourner et en fait chaque lofteurs
est venu avec un secret non avoué depuis
20 ans oui franchement il fallait les
chercher on avait tout dit sur cette
façon chic et non sur le loft pardon
s'appuyer sur le neuf on a encore
beaucoup de choses à vous raconter ce tv
on accueille la prochaine ensemble avec
alors à l'époque on va pas se mentir à
laver une image un peu particulière une
histoire hors en europe elle avait un
caractère extrêmement bien trempé on a
un peu de surnommer un peu la peste de
la maison quand même la connaître à
tempérament de feu le feu kenza est né à
bagdad il ya 24 ans commercial en
informatique
c'est une jeune femme indépendante qui
reste très attaché à sa famille
moussa va et toi et toi mais bien à
bâtir ça fait encore je t'ai pas vu bah
oui je te rappelle quand j'étais quand
j'étais grosse oui tu t'es bien ou
plutôt ouais ouais j'étais monde
j'étais très complexe et ça que j'étais
un bon jour tu t'es pris en main tu l'as
dit bon alors maintenant sport régime
exactement tu as commencé à affirmer
avec les garçons mais pour trouver
l'homme idéal
elle a récemment passé une petite
annonce sur internet j'ai à peu près
jusqu'à depuis deux semaines 150
messages c'est pas toujours l'idéal
qu'on rencontre sur internet
mais bon qu'est ce qu'on tente de
deviner deuxième candidat oui c'est
kenza ces quêtes
on n'a pas changé
ah là là j'ai l'impression de remonter
le temps honnêtement c'est un truc de
fou vient ma clé dans la lah
[Applaudissements]
la fin s'embrasser mais non on peut
passer embrassez vous restez à distance
est 13e au total c'est très contente et
bah pareil tu as pas beaucoup changé
vrai nom d'hergé une photo ou garde du
garçon qui présentait l'émission oui ne
sais pas le même non c'est pas
franchement tu as beaucoup maigri quand
même j'ai beaucoup mais c'est pourquoi
mes toiles à l'étoile a avec la wii et
la petite valise qui chargé comme maman
alors je veux je veux je répète dans
cette valise il ya évidemment des choses
qu'on n'a pas encore dit sur l'émission
l'intérêt des choses toute la soirée on
va défiler l'histoire de cet accroc mais
l'émission parce que franchement on a
vécu un truc de dingue tous ensemble
c'est vrai que c'est pierre très heureux
je suis très heureux parce que nous été
revu mais dans ce qui arrive il y en a
que je vous jure c'est vrai je les ai
pas vus depuis 20 ans à qui ils sont
rentrés et de pulsions sortie est depuis
20 ans je ne sais franchement nous on
n'est jamais content je suis très
excitée c'était alex appel retrouver en
eburnie bas alors alors cela cela ils
vont arriver tous les deux ça vous donne
un indice évidemment ils se sont
rencontrés dans la maison depuis ils ont
vécu des tâches chaudes et se sont
mariés ils ont eu plein d'enfants ce
n'est pas un conte de fées c'est la
réalité ce n'est pas de la télé réalité
portrait julie à 25 ans elle travaille à
la réception d'un grand hôtel parisien
tout près des champs elysées
elle se définit elle même comme une
jeune femme moderne une jeune femme qui
n'a pas froid aux yeux d'un enfant
regardant faire pour séduire mais aussi
se faire plaisir aux gens
on dirait le sud
un endroit très gai
bonjour je m'appelle christophe j'ai 24
ans je suis ancien parisien j'ai été
adopté par cette ville magnifique vous
pouvez voir autour de vous du soir aussi
je vous avais quelque chose un petit
secret que c'est vrai que j'aime bien
faire un petit strip tease dans la
fenêtre mais attendez un soft un jeu
reste voilà avec mes potes vous a
réservé une petite surprise va vous
montrer ce que c'est que de la vraie
musique qui existe à toulouse depuis un
sacré moment en europe
[Musique]
s'il concerne mon chapelet d'îles
sioniste un peu naturiste sur les bords
et le corps c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est très simple
j'aime la vie et j'aime m'amuser et
prend la vie du bon côté c'est tout
simplement la la la la et alors qu'ils
sont évidemment la voiture où il l'avait
reconnu forcément c'est christophe et
julie christophe est illogique
oui
à l'époque non c'est judy dans l'est
dans l'émission depuis se sont mariés
ils ont eu deux enfants et ce point qui
sont venus d'ailleurs avec leurs enfants
le verra tout à l'heure à a
venez m
à
mais comme à l'époque
alors là on va pas vous mentir on sait
on s'est revus newey on a eu l'occasion
ces revues mais écoutez pareil faisait
pas beaucoup changé vous un peu les
cheveux il y en a moins
mais j'ai déjà pas beaucoup ouais c'est
vrai mais vous êtes très très bon merci
beaucoup c'est bien c'est sans vraiment
alors petite photo avec la valise que
baal est oui alors je ne sais pas quels
secrets vous nous avez ramené auquel oui
ça me concerne pas un petit peu à merde
à tant qu'à faire
la chaîne cryptée
alors il paraît qu'ils étaient excités
en loge il était dans un étal la
surexcitation même on avait envie qu'on
fait part vu la photo la coloniale et
pendant ce temps là alors là je vous dis
allah pour moi c'est un événement parce
que la candidate qui arrive maintenant
je vous jure que c'est vrai ça fait
exactement 20 ans que je ne les ai
jamais revus de ma vie et en plus elle a
une histoire particulièrement dans la
maison parce que l est pas resté là je
vous donne un indice à l'est pas resté
très longtemps son surnom c'était la
belle des champs regarder le portrait km
de tarbes
delphine a ouvert il ya deux ans son
propre poney club
elle s'occupe d'une quarantaine de
chevaux et gère une centaine de clients
alors dans cet emploi du temps surchargé
il y a peu de place pour les garçons
en rapport avec les hormones session jeu
de la séduction comme comme beaucoup de
personnes j'aime ça mais c'est vrai
qu'ils ont un emploi du temps on
travaille tous les animaux j'ai quand
même veine ses deux chevaux à montcuq et
[Musique]
sensible et solitaire delphine et malgré
tout prête à tout quitter pour une
aventure à l'opposé de son quotidien
et oui c'est donc delphine qui fait son
apparition
vraiment tu rentrais ses débuts vraiment
ça fait vraiment 20 ans est passé pas
moins deux fois alors là franchement
ah la la
c'est pareil mais tu n'as pas changé on
peut ne pas s'embrasser vraiment bon
allez de loi alors voilà bien les filles
ça fait on va le dire
vingt ans qu'on ne sait pas jamais
croisé c'est vrai j'aime mais
heureusement elle est restée une semaine
dans la maison
oui après les partis de la maison mais
dans le coeur des gens vous avez fait
partie de l'aventuré en entier battus à
venir et voilà qu'au début depuis 20 ans
je vous vois ccbc bête bon petite photo
ouais y'a des trucs sympas dans la
valise j'imagine allez on va maintenant
accueillir devait même écarter le
prochain candidat alors oui j'ai revu
mes ce qui était amusant c'est qu'en
fait c'est ce jeune est surnommé en fait
le candidat furtif de la maison c'est
que il a fait le lof et finalement il
est passé un peu au travers de tous 1 il
est resté assez longtemps dans la maison
portait vous allez le reconnaître
fabrice 29 ans vient ici tous les jours
s'adonner à sa passion le jonglage une
activité qui correspond parfaitement à
sa philosophie de la vie
j'ai revendiqué la liberté profiter à
chaque fois de plus possible du moment
du moment présent saisir toutes les
toutes les opportunités même un parfum
une odeur c'est ya plein de magie autour
de nous il suffit d'ouvrir les yeux en
fait fabrice guy seul
enfin pas tout à fait ils partagent
quasiment toutes les nuits ensemble
presque toutes les lignes c'est vrai
qu'il est de nature elle un petit peu
jaloux et possessif
donc si si je fais des rencontres un
soir et ch nara manche dizale chemin
avec ses potes pour un jeu passionnant
il n'y pas trop orageuse à cause de
luttes elle est donc la sortie de
fabrice alors fabrice justement fabrice
à l'époque il était rentré et les rails
et est rentré plus tard dans l'aventuré
qui l'avait remplacé un corps du net qui
avait abandonné l aventure là vous
saurez comment ça va non non c'est
renoncer au vigeant voilà c'est un
candidat il a réussi à traverser les
missions et il a uni cité va lasser à
l'homme invisible pour moi et puis pour
s'en va il est encore là en tout cas je
suis ravie de rentrer d'être ici pour
les 20 ans tous mes petits camarades
ça va être une super bonne sans riches
il ya des bouleaux des quads qui en plus
je crois qu'il est oui oui oui il arrête
fabrice on va cuire maintenant le
dernier candidat lui aussi je le dis lui
aussi ça fait ça fait vraiment 20 ans
que je n'ai pas revu c'était l'un des
plus emblématiques de l'émission
vous avez évidemment le reconnaître si
je vous dis si vous donner un indice dj
ça vous aide pas beaucoup et pourtant
c'est son métier
portrait
salut je m'appelle jean edouard j'ai 20
ans j'habite aix en provence et j'ai une
grande passion pour les disques parce
que je suis une jouerie douars et
étudiants en bts il est aussi dj dans un
bar branché d'aix en provence
outre les vinyles ce séducteur né a
plutôt la réputation de collectionner
les filles et plus d'une rêverait de
passer sur ses platines ce supplément
d'amour jo edwards le trouve auprès de
sa mère probablement que la personne
qu'il aime le plus c'est moi personne ne
l'aiment autant que sa mère personne ne
l'aiment autant que sa mère et oui c'est
le sait le jean-edouard de l'époque il
avait quasiment disparu des radars
c'est l'un des personnages des plus
belles et des plus grandes aventures
alors vraiment et je suis content pour
aller dans les bars
20h20 et c'est l'europe a 20 ans quand
ses parents
exactement je crois bien qu'on sait même
pas croisés à l'époque là on sait pas
mais une semaine seulement ont séparé ya
une scène par téléphone on a préparé
évidemment l'émission semble qu'ils
avaient tous ceux ils avaient manqué d
angoisse voulais que ce soit bien le
surfing good ils sont affirme le dr ya
cru du feel good
la diatribe du feel good bon j'ai pas
présenté en parlant de la piscine on va
parler un peu mais on peut a alors les
lames la petite photo on veut avec la
valise parce que signé de doria quelques
anecdotes croustillantes paraît-il avant
tout à l'arrivée je crois je crois alors
puisque puisque elle a fait la finale
tout fait la photo est ce que jean
edouard et là où ils pensaient ensemble
pour le 1 à loana vous le savez on n'est
pas très en forme en plus elle a eu à la
fin de rap locaux vite qu'elle est assez
fortement
donc on embrasse qu'on va quand même
essayer dû téléphoner dans la soirée en
espoirs de la puce me répondre mais bon
on lui souhaite un bon rétablissement et
on embrasse très fort